When Jeff Bezos announced he was
blasting off to space in the summer,
there was a petition that he
shouldn’t return to Earth.
Actually, there were quite a few.
Questions like this often pop up online:
“Why do people like Elon
Musk and dislike Jeff Bezos?”
And Musk has just been named the
2021 Time person of the year.
We’re going to examine the reasons Musk
has an army of fangirls and fanboys
whereas Bezos not so much, and why Musk is
starting to alienate some people as well.
A Quora user gave his two cents on
why he thinks Musk is more likable:
Maybe because…He engages people
more via his social media.
Musk loves to respond to the
general public on Twitter,
allowing him to build a powerful connection
with his 65 million and counting followers.
He shares memes, dad jokes, inappropriate
jokes - the opposite of a carefully crafted
corporate image which appeals to his fan base.
When Bezos uses Twitter, he’s super professional.
Like this tweet about how Amazon
proved its early doubters wrong.
Musk poked fun at him by replying
with a silver medal emoji.
Bezos didn’t bother responding but his rocket
company Blue Origin has blasted Musk’s SpaceX,
labeling SpaceX’s Starship lunar
lander 'immensely complex & high risk'.
NASA didn’t think so when it awarded SpaceX
a contract to return American astronauts
to the moon. Blue Origin protested the
decision by suing and ended up losing,
prompting Musk to share this meme of Judge Dredd
from the film saying: you have been judged.
Bezos’ space venture is still
trying to catch up to SpaceX.
Although Blue Origin has now flown
humans to space on New Shepard,
it has never sent them into orbit around
Earth, something SpaceX accomplished in 2020.
It has been a long and difficult road
to get SpaceX to where it is today.
Musk has opened up about his company often to the
point of tears like in this 60 Minutes interview.
So it’s really tough
Letting out his emotions makes
him appear real and relatable.
His blood sweat and tears are all in the
name of trying to build a city on Mars.
I call upon the public to support this goal.
His supporters believe he’s
the savior of humanity.
Comparing him to Tony Stark aka
Iron Man whereas Bezos has been
likened to Dr. Evil which possibly has
something to do with him being bald.
It might also have something to
do with his riches from Amazon.
Bezos grew Amazon into the behemoth it is
today by brilliantly giving shoppers what
they wanted when they didn’t even know
they wanted it, like same-day delivery.
Amazon accounts for nearly 40 percent of
all online retail shopping in the U.S.
Despite his stunning success, e-commerce
isn’t all that sexy so it doesn’t attract
the kind of fans you’d get if
you developed cool products,
like what Steve Jobs did with Apple, or what
Musk is doing with electric cars at Tesla.
Not to mention Amazon has its
chorus of critics accusing it of
acting like a monopoly and of mistreating workers.
Headlines describe delivery drivers
working long days with no bathroom breaks,
reportedly peeing in bottles, and warehouse
workers being pressured to work even faster.
Bezos has defended the treatment of Amazon’s
staff but acknowledged the company needs to do
a better job in his final letter to shareholders
before he stepped down as CEO earlier in 2021.
One of the reasons he stepped away
was to focus on his space company.
Up until recently, Blue Origin
wasn’t all that well-known.
When it IS in the spotlight,
Bezos has gotten flak.
When he chose to rocket to space on the first
Blue Origin flight carrying passengers, Democratic
senator Elizabeth Warren was not too pleased about
what she called a “joy ride” by a billionaire.
And on the following flight that took
Star Trek star William Shatner to space,
he appeared to interrupt Shatner’s
emotional post-fight speech.
Because you’re shooting up.
Give me a champagne bottle,
come here. I want one. I want to hear
this. Here, you want a little of this?
Some people called out Bezos for this moment.
Musk has gotten his fair share of bad press, too.
Tesla has recently faced lawsuits
alleging sexual harassment and
racist abuse at its Fremont factory in California,
and a complaint that it failed to tell the
public that its solar panels could catch fire.
Musk has apparently responded to the
whistleblowing by promoting a new Tesla product,
the Cyberwhistle inspired by the Cybertruck.
He even tweeted: “Blow the whistle on Tesla!”
Further cementing the belief that
he doesn’t act like a typical CEO
which again plays to his fan base.
However, the cult of Elon
may be showing some cracks.
Especially with his tweets about the pandemic.
He’s called the coronavirus panic dumb.
Falsely predicted there would be no new
cases of covid in the US by April 2020
And defied a local lockdown order
to reopen Tesla’s Fremont factory.
He also once called a diver who
refused his offer of a submarine
to save Thai boys trapped in a cave
a “pedo guy” in a now deleted tweet.
When Musk surpassed Bezos to become
the richest person in the world in
early 2021 - his wealth appears
to have rubbed some the wrong way.
Democratic senator Bernie Sanders has
been demanding billionaires be taxed
more to which Musk responded: I keep
forgetting that you’re still alive.
The United Nations food program director,
David Beasley called on billionaires and
specifically Musk to donate $6 billion,
or 2% of his wealth, to help solve
world hunger during an interview on CNN.
Wake up, smell the coffee, and help.
In response, Musk said: "If WFP
can describe on this Twitter thread
exactly how $6B will solve world hunger, I
will sell Tesla stock right now and do it."
Beasley clarified that the money is needed to
solve the current crisis, not all world hunger.
Whether you’re a billionaire, millionaire,
or just someone with concern for others,
it can be difficult to know the best
way to give to have the greatest impact.
That’s why the work of my
sponsor GiveWell is so crucial.
GiveWell is a non-profit that does
in-depth research on the charities
that do the best job saving or improving lives.
They figure out how far your dollar goes
so you can rest assured that your
donations are being used effectively.
For example, they recommend Helen Keller
International’s Vitamin A Supplementation Program
that provides the key nutrient for vision, growth,
and immunity to children in sub-Saharan Africa.
GiveWell publishes all of their research and
recommendations on their website for FREE
and you don’t have to sign up to see it.
If you’d like to make a difference in
someone’s life this holiday season,
GiveWell is matching donations from first-time
donors dollar for dollar up to $250.
Click on the link below in my description
to donate and be sure to use the fundraiser
code NEWSTHINK at checkout to make
sure your donation gets matched.
They allocate your tax-deductible donation to
the charity you choose without
taking anything for themselves.
If you don’t have a charity in mind, they
recommend their Maximum Impact Fund which
directs donations to the charities that GiveWell
has determined to be most effective each quarter.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom